Hi everyone, I'm Fabio from Free Wings and today we're going to look at meteorology together.
This is mainly about exam preparation, or about meteo basics in general.
For me, there are two ways to approach learning meteorology.
One is the minimum-effort approach — just getting through the theory exam somehow.
And then of course there's a lot more weather knowledge you can teach and learn.
There are basically no limits there — you could spend five days just talking about meteorology.
But this course really focuses on the basics.
It's also suitable for experienced pilots,
to refresh their weather knowledge a bit or learn some new things.
There are definitely some interesting topics in here for experienced pilots too.
But this course is of course mainly designed for flight schools,
so we can hopefully give you a good grasp of weather knowledge —
stuff that might be rather dry in the theory book and a bit hard to understand.
And so let's dive into the fascinating field of weather knowledge.
One thing that's always very close to my heart, especially in meteorology,
is that there are basically two sides to it.
On one hand you have theoretical weather knowledge, where you can learn a lot and understand a lot of theory.
But in meteorology, the weather happens out there in the open.
It has a lot to do with experience — flight practice or hands-on meteo practice.
A lot of it is about observing the weather over and over, analyzing it,
and constantly matching theory with practice.
And that's really important.
But in this section, it's mainly about theory and building a basic understanding of the weather.
Let's start with the biggest picture. Where does the weather actually happen?
It happens in our atmosphere.
The atmosphere around the world is divided into different layers.
The stratosphere, mesosphere, troposphere.
But the most relevant one for us is the troposphere,
which is bounded at the top by what's called the tropopause.
And this lower layer is where most of the humidity is found,
most of the water vapour — and so it's what determines our weather.
This troposphere is extremely thin.
When you look from space, from a space station,
it's just a very thin layer that you can see here.
In scale, it's about as thin as an onion skin.
It's really a very, very thin band where weather phenomena take place,
and of course where we move around too.
And we, as paraglider pilots, actually only move in the lowest layer of this troposphere.
And...
Something important from the theory — you also need to know this for the theory exam —
the composition of the gases in this troposphere.
There's the 21% oxygen, which is of course what we need to breathe,
78% nitrogen, and then there's 1% noble gas,
which is also part of the mix.
But for us, for meteorology, that's not of much relevance —
the remaining noble gases in there.
The troposphere isn't equally thick all the way around the globe.
It's a bit thinner at the poles than at the equator.
That has to do with the Earth's rotation.
At the equator it's about 18 km, and at the poles around 8 km.
Here in Europe, at our latitude where we do most of our flying,
the troposphere is about 11 to 13 km thick.
You have to picture it — 13,000 metres.
Then we talk about the standard atmosphere.
This keeps coming up in flight weather, and especially in the theory exam.
They'll keep asking you about the standard atmosphere.
It's that atmosphere where the weather would be completely balanced out —
no high-pressure areas, no low-pressure areas,
and none of the various factors that influence our weather,
which we'll look at in a moment.
If everything balanced out, you'd get what's called the standard atmosphere.
It's like the zero point, where everything has evened out.
There are a few numbers and facts you need to know for the theory exam.
The important one is the temperature gradient with altitude —
how the troposphere cools off.
We're talking about 6.5 degrees per 1000 metres,
or per 100 metres, that's 0.65 degrees per 100 metres.
At the Earth's surface, the standard atmosphere is 15 degrees,
and at the top of the troposphere it's minus 56 degrees.
The lower two numbers are especially important —
make sure you learn those for the theory exam.
The temperature gradient of course varies depending on the weather situation,
as we'll see later.
But in the standard atmosphere, as I said, it's 6.5 degrees per 100 metres.
So those are the temperatures.
In the standard atmosphere we also talk about a standard air pressure.
We can't really get into air pressure yet,
but the number we'll hear again and again
is 1013.25 hPa.
1013.25 hPa is the air pressure
when the entire troposphere balances out, as I mentioned.
Then, measured at sea level, the air pressure would always be the same.
And it would be 1013.25 hPa.
And the height of the troposphere, where the tropopause begins,
is at 11 kilometres in the standard atmosphere.
Another important thing about air pressure
is how it drops with altitude.
It's not linear.
You can say
that every 5500 metres of altitude, the air pressure halves.
So at 5500 metres we'd have 506.6 hPa.
That's also a value at 5500 metres
that's very important to learn for the theory exam.
So pressure of course decreases with altitude.
You can picture air pressure like this:
it's like a column of air
that's above us all the way up to the tropopause.
And it works the same way as in water, for example.
For those who dive,
the deeper you go into the water,
the higher the pressure becomes due to Earth's gravity.
And so naturally the air pressure is highest
at the lowest point, at sea level,
and decreases with altitude.
It has to do with gravity
and with the column of air
that acts on us
and generates air pressure.
Here are the numbers quickly summarized again:
1013.25, 15 degrees,
and 0.65 per 100 metres.
Those are the numbers
that are relevant for us
for the standard atmosphere.
Right.
And if we think about it,
the standard atmosphere
is of course never quite the same,
as we experience every day with the weather.
Enter the engine —
the sun,
which shines on the Earth and does its work.
And different land and sea regions
warm up differently.
Different seasons too.
With different angles of incidence
of the sun depending on the season.
You know how it is —
the sun isn't always at the same height.
And so the whole
system, the standard atmosphere,
gets thrown out of balance,
and there are fluctuations in air pressure
and all the various weather systems.
So the sun is a really important engine
that knocks things out of balance
and influences the weather in various ways.
And we're going to look at this together now —
what kind of influence it has.
The sun,
shining on the Earth,
primarily heats the ground.
That's really important.
The sun never heats an air mass
that it passes through.
Air doesn't reflect the sun
or heat up from it.
What it actually warms is
the air layer near the ground.
That's the air layer
that sits right on the ground.
Through the radiated heat
that gets given off,
the air layer near the ground heats up.
And because of this warming
of the air layer near the ground,
there are regions across the world,
spread across the globe,
that warm up differently.
Regions at the equator warm up
much more than a region
somewhere in the polar area,
where the sun's rays
only hit at a very shallow angle.
Likewise, an ice surface
warms up less
than, say, a desert
or a forested area, and so on.
And because of that,
different areas
on the globe heat up differently,
and this creates different
air masses.
When we talk about air masses —
that's another word
that comes up a lot in meteorology.
An air mass is
basically a volume of air
that has the same properties.
So we have, for instance, a warmer
air mass and a cooler one.
And these are always regions
that have the same properties
over several hundred kilometres —
the same air pressure,
or the same temperature,
or similar temperature,
a warmer or a colder temperature.
Basically, the rule is:
over an area that's been colder for longer
than its surroundings,
you'll get higher
air pressure.
And over an area that's been warm for longer
than its surroundings,
you get lower pressure.
Accordingly, in the tropical
regions, for example, you have the tropical
low-pressure areas, and in the
polar regions you have the polar
high-pressure areas.
That's how different air pressures arise.
And then the low-pressure areas
and high-pressure areas form,
which we'll get into
in the next slides,
what kind of influence that
has on our weather.
You can imagine these
as belts around the world.
Around the globe there are what's called
high-pressure cells.
These are low- and high-pressure rings.
There are even more than what's shown in this graphic.
But basically, in
the tropical regions you get a
low-pressure belt, and in the polar regions you get
a high-pressure belt.
And so you also get tropical
air masses and polar
air masses. And here too, we'll
learn over the next few minutes
what kind of influence that has
on our weather.
We just covered this.
Different regions
warm up to different degrees.
So you get a high-pressure area
and a low-pressure area.
And here in the middle you can see
the numbers we just had
from this standard atmosphere,
the 1013.25.
And as soon as the air pressure drops
and is lower,
we're talking about a low-pressure area.
Here in Europe,
a very pronounced
low-pressure area is around
955 hPa.
And a very pronounced
high-pressure area would be around
1035 hPa.
Now in this age of global warming,
the values are unfortunately also getting
more extreme. There are even
high-pressure systems that reach, for example,
1048 hPa.
So those are
very strong pressure differences.
And accordingly,
the meteorological phenomena are getting stronger too.
And that's something we
unfortunately keep experiencing.
These severe weather events, for example,
have a lot to do with
these pressure swings that keep getting stronger.
Something else that's important
for us to know —
we'll get back to the connection later —
is that
in high-pressure areas the air masses
sink, and in low-pressure areas
the air masses rise. That'll be
really important later on
for flight weather, which we'll
get to in a bit.
And basically, like every gas
or every liquid,
air masses have
the urge to equalize pressure.
That means
an air mass always wants to flow from
high pressure to low pressure,
because it wants to equalize the pressure.
And accordingly, especially
at ground level or in the
lower air layers, this
airflow is important, that
air flows from high to low,
and that's how
the winds form,
the wind systems that we
feel at ground level when the wind blows.
And
so there's an equalizing flow,
which is important for us
to identify these wind directions
and read them out.
Then we come to
isobar charts — a word that
you've surely heard before or read about
in the theory book. There are
weather charts that describe
exactly these weather phenomena we just discussed.
These weather charts
come from a combination of
current measurements,
where barometers measure the
air pressure, and
of course the computer models,
which then use those measurements
to try and forecast
and predict the weather.
And then you end up with
these fun weather charts,
which we'll now look at in more detail
and learn how to read.
Isobar charts —
isobars
are the lines
you see here. Isobars
describe areas
that have the same air pressure.
Or where the same
air pressure is forecast.
So we have, for instance, an isobar
at 1025 hPa —
you can't see it well here, but in the next
chart it's easier to see.
And everywhere that line runs,
at sea level — this is really important,
the pressure is reduced to
sea level — the same air pressure
is present. That's where the name
isobar charts comes from.
Iso = equal, bar = pressure.
So everywhere the same pressure
occurs, this kind of line is
drawn. And on such an
isobar chart, fronts are often
marked too, of course — we'll get into that
in more detail later in this course,
what these fronts look
like.
Here you can see slightly bigger isobar charts,
showing again the high-pressure areas,
low-pressure areas we just discussed,
where different air pressure has
developed, due to the sun and
the seasons, for example.
And that's
what a somewhat larger
isobar chart looks like. They always look a bit
different, depending on the newspaper
or meteo service.
They look a bit different, but in principle
they all have the same elements
in them. There are again the high and
low-pressure areas, isobars, and
the colored lines, the
fronts. Right.
That's what it also looks like. Now once again,
shown simply on our
globe, the different pressure areas
that form over various land and
sea masses.
They have different pressure — again
low-pressure — and
due to the Coriolis force,
which is a
physical phenomenon caused by
the Earth's rotation,
different
air masses,
as they start to move,
get deflected.
And that produces
cyclical movements —
rotating movements.
Picture it like
a drain for instance —
due to various forces
or the shape of the drain you get
a whirlpool. When
the water flows down the drain,
it starts to rotate.
And so a rotational motion arises.
In the air mass it's
mainly the Coriolis force that's responsible
for the
air masses starting to
rotate. And consequently,
on the northern side
of our globe,
everything north of
the equator, it's the case
that in a high-pressure area
the air masses rotate
clockwise, and
in a low-pressure area
counterclockwise.
I came up with a memory trick:
a high-pressure area is something positive for me,
because then the sun shines and the
weather is nice and it's flying weather.
So it's something positive.
And to me, clockwise is
time running forward — in a positive sense.
Moving forward, I built that as a memory aid:
in a high-pressure area
clockwise, in a low-pressure area
counterclockwise — the rotation.
In the southern
hemisphere, for example
in Australia, the whole thing
works exactly the opposite.
Just for those of you who fly off on holiday
and go flying in South America,
or in Australia,
there it's exactly reversed.
You can see this very impressively
of course in the case of
a hurricane. You can really see
how the air mass rotates. A
hurricane is nothing other than
an extreme low-pressure area,
and you can see —
this is a hurricane,
it's in the northern
hemisphere — you can see how it
rotates counterclockwise
and gets sucked into the low-pressure
area, this air mass.
You can see it
very nicely in this
cloud image of a hurricane.
And accordingly — we saw earlier
in the slide that the air mass
wants to equalize the pressure, it flows
from high pressure into the low-pressure area,
but it doesn't flow in a direct
line from
high to low, instead it gets
deflected, as the Coriolis force describes,
into a rotating motion
as it moves between the areas.
So the
air mass goes in this
spiral motion
right into the low-pressure area.
To read out the wind direction,
we'll look at that
on the chart in a moment —
we'll see again in a few
slides later how you read
the wind direction off an isobar chart.
You can also read
wind strength
from this isobar chart.
Maybe to describe it visually,
you can think of an isobar chart
a bit like a
topographic map.
Those are different contour lines —
different pressure lines — and accordingly
a high-pressure area, for example, can
be of different heights.
So a high-pressure influence can
be of varying strength.
We might have, for instance,
a 50er of a high-pressure area —
extremely strong, it has lots of
isobar lines, lots of contour lines
in the landscape sense.
Or it could just be a hill,
but the H
really only describes the
highest pressure point — basically
the highest elevation in the landscape
or of that hill.
And so it can be higher
or less high. And accordingly
the weather effects,
which we'll discuss in a moment,
are stronger or weaker.
What we're going to do is quickly look at
how to read a wind direction
off such an isobar chart.
Basically we have —
this is an infographic from a
theory exam, like the one you'll get —
we have different pressure areas,
like the ones we've seen.
Of course they won't make your exam
so easy that they put an H and a T
in there for you so you immediately know where the
high and low-pressure areas are. So
they want you to read the pressure
off these isobars, and
you see for example here over Scandinavia,
it's relatively hard to read,
80 hPa for instance.
You know that's below
1013.25.
So that has to be a low pressure.
So there you can imagine,
you can even write a T in there
if you want.
And so we know that the
air mass in this low-pressure area
rotates counterclockwise.
And then you can,
if you want, draw arrows
onto these isobar lines you see here,
or you can also just
picture it —
imagine arrows on the
isobar lines.
I've shown them in white here,
and that's how you read the wind direction.
So for example here
in England we have
a westerly wind flow.
And in the high-pressure area,
here we have 1030 hPa,
that's where the highest elevation is,
that's where the high pressure is, that's where it rotates
clockwise, and so
the wind follows the isobars.
And you can really
see, for the theory it's the case
that the wind is always read
parallel to the isobars.
So you really take the line,
and that's the wind direction,
because the pressure equalizes
in a circulating motion.
Right, that's for the wind direction.
You can also picture
high- and low-pressure areas
as working like a gear system.
You can imagine
them as two gears
that mesh into each other —
you might find that easier to picture.
How to read the wind,
we'll now look at
in the next slides.
One thing that's relevant for the wind
is the wind direction.
We need to know what wind direction to expect,
which launch site to go to,
where it's perhaps more relevant,
also for various weather phenomena.
You can picture
a compass rose with north 0 degrees,
east 90 degrees, south 180 degrees,
west 270 degrees.
And so the wind
is sometimes given in degrees,
out of these 360 degrees.
A wind direction is always described
by where the wind comes from.
If the wind comes from the south,
we call it a south wind —
north wind, west wind, of course.
So the air mass comes from the west
and that makes it a west wind.
And so the degrees
are given accordingly.
If we have a wind from 90 degrees,
then picture the compass rose
and the wind comes
from 90 degrees, from the east.
That's really important,
because on the meteo theory exam
the wind will keep being given
in degrees.
And then you need to know
what they're talking about —
are they talking about a south wind or an east wind, and so on.
Then there's also wind strength.
We just covered wind direction.
Wind strength comes in
various units.
In aviation,
and this comes mostly from aviation,
the wind is usually
given in knots.
There's a simple formula.
Wind in knots —
so in the upper example
nautical knots,
times 2 minus 10%
gives you km/h.
So kilometres per hour of wind.
Which for us is a bit
the standard unit
for wind speeds,
we can picture it better.
And at most weather stations
for instance, the wind is given in km/h.
Times 2 gives 40, minus 10%,
that's 4,
gives 36 km/h of wind.
The conversion is important,
make sure you have it on the tip of your tongue
and ready for the theory exam.
Then, something else you can include
in the wind topic
is the wind gradient.
If you imagine
a wind system coming in here,
with a westerly wind,
and it glides over the Earth's surface,
the wind aloft
is usually stronger,
while down at the ground the wind has friction,
so it becomes slower,
but also somewhat more turbulent.
So there are
some basic rules:
in low layers,
in ground-level layers,
the wind is weaker but more turbulent,
and in higher air layers
it's stronger but more laminar.
Logically, then, there are also
various meteorological phenomena,
where perhaps occasionally
a more turbulent air mass
can be aloft, or the whole thing,
and a basic rule is:
if you know a wind flow,
it's weaker and more turbulent at the ground.
So that's the wind gradient.
A gradient, by the way, is always
a progression — in this sense,
with altitude.
We'll also hear about a temperature gradient
later in the theory course.
It always refers to a progression
with altitude when you talk about a gradient,
or in general a progression.
But in meteorology it's
mainly about altitude.
Another topic that belongs to wind,
that's especially important for us paraglider pilots,
is turbulence.
We want a calm flight if possible,
or rather, when there is turbulence,
we want to be prepared and know
why this turbulence forms
and how we can perhaps
anticipate it a little,
and in which areas we should fly,
or maybe not.
There are basically three types
of turbulence that we distinguish,
which also come up on the theory exam.
First of all, certainly the best turbulence —
which can be pleasant,
but maybe also less pleasant —
is thermal turbulence.
That's probably the one we're
exposed to the most when flying,
because we want to fly thermally,
so we're always moving
in thermal air masses.
And those who have felt it before
know what I'm talking about.
It's like this: when an air mass rises,
the air mass is basically relatively calm —
it sits here, and then the thermal
turbulences rise, which we'll look at
later in detail.
And in this rising zone there are
often small downdraft zones around the edges
of thermal updrafts.
And so you get wind shears
in the vertical.
And in these wind shears
you of course feel the turbulence —
that's the thermal turbulence.
Then there's wind shear in another sense.
That's when
we have two different wind directions —
if down low we have west wind
and up top we have, or no,
down low we might still have a bit of
Bise mixed in, so east wind,
up top we have west wind.
Then there's sometimes a mixing layer
where the two wind systems meet.
And exactly at
those altitudes where the winds
meet, you get what's called a shear wind.
And there too we
perceive turbulence, or a light
turbulence, depending on wind strength.
For us paraglider pilots
this isn't especially relevant.
But sometimes we feel things,
that there's a layer that rumbles a bit.
For instance, due to a real wind.
We'll come back to that later.
With mechanical turbulence,
that's the third topic,
it's about when an
air mass flows over an object,
for instance a forest, or a house,
or something — or even,
and this is what's most relevant for us,
a mountain range for instance —
when we have strong wind there,
and it flows over this object,
you might know it from those
airflow videos of cars and such,
and then behind the object you get
turbulent eddies,
which can be very unpleasant.
Depending on wind strength
they can be very unpleasant,
or even dangerous.
But when the wind is rather weak,
they're sometimes just subtly noticeable.
Especially at the landing site this is important,
if you'd be landing behind a house.
If you have strong wind,
that's of course not really an advantage.
Maybe two more words here
that come up again and again in flying:
windward and lee.
That's a topic we'll also
look at briefly.
The lee side always describes
the side facing away from the wind,
and the windward side is the side facing into the wind.
The question always is,
from whose perspective?
From our perspective?
From an object's perspective?
Or — you hear it,
you hear a lot of talk at the launch site,
for instance also on mountain ridges.
Down there we have a lee side,
and that's seen from the mountain's perspective —
the back side of the mountain,
when the airflow hits the mountain.
Or in this sense maybe
a house — a lee side of the house
and a windward side of the house.
When landing you want exactly the same.
We land on the windward side,
as seen from the landing site,
on the windward side,
the side facing into the wind.
So that's windward and lee.
Something you'll hear over and over
in your training and in meteo theory.
Then we come to the last
weather phenomenon
involving wind,
which is also really really important for us
as paraglider pilots.
And that's understanding
the Venturi effect.
The so-called Venturi effect
you might know from aerodynamics theory.
You'll go through it there in more detail.
The Venturi effect
is about this:
whenever a wind flow
or an air mass
is forced
to narrow,
in the first example
for instance a valley — if we have a wide valley
that narrows to a smaller one
and the wind gets pushed through there,
a valley wind for example,
then in the narrowing of the valley
you get a wind acceleration.
So there you have significantly stronger wind
than on the wide side of the valley.
So of course, if you're flying
and expect a lot of wind,
land in an open valley
rather than in a narrow gorge,
for example.
That's the Venturi effect.
When you're on a mountain
or on a hill
and an air mass comes in,
you can picture it:
nice parallel lines come in,
the wind comes in
and then we have a hill
where the air mass is forced to rise,
and that leads to a narrowing
over the hill or on the mountain ridge above,
and so the wind speed
on top of the mountain is at its strongest.
So if you stand on a mountain
and launch, or on a hill,
and there's very strong wind,
then descend, if you can,
depending on what the terrain allows,
a few hundred metres,
and you'll notice that in the lower layer
the wind is usually much weaker
than right up on top,
right in the compression.
It's also something
we'll perhaps look at with soaring
in flight practice
or that you may have already done.
Of course what's important is
we want to stay in exactly the zone
where the updraft is,
where the wind is rising.
Leading to an acceleration of the wind,
because of the Venturi effect.
Right.
So we've looked at wind systems,
low-pressure areas, high-pressure areas.
We've learned how to read wind from
the isobars,
and also how to read wind strength.
Because the closer the isobars are together,
the stronger the wind.
And the further apart the isobars are —
think of a topographic map,
a landscape map —
the further apart the isobars are,
the weaker the pressure gradient,
the weaker
the equalizing flow between
these pressure areas.
It's really important that we
piece together the various topics
as a whole.
The deeper your understanding becomes
of what's happening with these air masses,
the more you can put together.
It's like a jigsaw puzzle,
where one piece fits into another.
Then flight weather
becomes a fascinating field
and you enjoy
understanding the fundamentals
and understanding the basics.
That's why the course is important:
so you understand the basics
and not just memorize stuff.
We'll go on with that
in the next slides.
The only topic that we
haven't yet looked at
on the isobar chart
are the fronts —
the blue, red and purple lines
with the various symbols on them.
These lead to special
meteorological conditions
which for us as paraglider pilots
are really important
to understand
and to grasp the dangers of these fronts.
But to understand fronts,
let's go back once more
to how a front actually forms.
How does a front form?
The air masses on the globe
warm up differently.
We have a colder air mass
up in the polar region
and a warmer, moist air mass
in the tropical or subtropical region.
And we covered earlier:
an air mass describes
an area, a volume of air
that has similar properties.
So we have two different air masses
and in between there's an
air-mass boundary.
And this air-mass boundary
is described by a front.
We have the blue triangles,
those describe a cold front,
and we have the red bumps,
so the round symbols,
those describe a warm front.
Below there's also a mixed form,
an occlusion, which we'll get to
later — that's the third form
of front that exists.
So you can imagine,
we have the different air masses,
and now we have, for example,
a low-pressure area that creates a vortex.
Picture maybe in the extreme case
a hurricane.
It's like a huge vortex,
it's a mixer that swirls the air masses
around and so
fronts start to form.
An air mass might draw from the north
toward the south, and a warmer air mass
draws from the south toward the north,
and accordingly a front system
starts to move. An air mass is
moved and accordingly
gets exchanged.
And so step by step
the fronts form.
Now you can picture this:
we have two wind directions for the low-pressure area
that start to rotate,
which brings the whole system into rotation
and accordingly
forms these fronts.
What you can see nicely here
is that first
a warm front leads the way,
the red line,
and we have a cold front
that comes behind.
We'll look at this in a moment.
A cold front moves faster
than a warm front.
A cold front is almost twice as fast
as a warm front.
And so it happens that
the cold front
catches up with the warm front
and you can see it here
in the center of the low pressure —
at some point occlusions form.
An occlusion describes
a mixed form of these two fronts.
We'll now get into more
detail on
what that means and what it looks like.
We can see here
how the air masses rotate
and how the various front systems
form from the two air masses.
Let's first look at the cold front.
It's almost the most important front,
or the most dangerous front,
for paraglider pilots.
A cold front comes in —
you can picture this:
in this graphic it moves from left to right.
The cold air mass pushes
in underneath, since it's heavier.
So it pushes in underneath
and it comes in
in a teardrop shape. You can remember:
the shape of this line
in the vertical is a teardrop
coming in.
So cold air pushes in underneath.
The warmer air is lighter
and so it wants to rise.
And so you get a
large-scale
rising of this warm,
moist air mass.
And clouds form in this rising process,
which at some point rain out
and in the extreme form
of course produce thunderstorms.
So with a really active cold front,
thunderstorms always come along.
And these thunderstorms
of course mean very strong wind
or very strong gusts.
That's of course for paragliding
extremely dangerous.
What's a problem with the cold front,
is that ahead of the cold front
we usually have nice weather.
There's sunshine,
the weather is nice,
it makes you want to fly.
Maybe there's a bit of wind.
In Switzerland it's often accompanied
by west wind, or southwest wind,
or a bit of Foehn,
we'll come to that later.
But it's usually accompanied by some wind,
and often you also get good
weather charts.
Things are rising, which is basically
what we want.
But if on this weather chart,
the isobar chart
we hopefully briefly study before flying,
we see that a cold front
is coming in, then we really have to
be cautious as paraglider pilots,
because that comes with a lot of wind
and a lot of rising
air masses, where we really
need to land quickly too.
With a cold front it's really appropriate
to factor in the daily timing.
A cold front comes in at 40 to 70 km/h,
so it can be relatively fast,
really important. The wind can of course
become much stronger near thunderstorms,
and it takes about 6 to 12 hours
for it to pass over Switzerland.
So it can sometimes be a relatively quick thing.
Right.
So be careful
with these cold fronts.
Really important: if you're flying ahead
of a cold front, keep
checking the weather radar, and especially
keep your eyes on the sky.
The thunderstorms come after,
and it looks roughly like this.
We'll also look at the topic of thunderstorms
in more detail in this course.
But here's a rule of thumb for you:
when thunderstorms come in a line
on the weather radar like it looks here,
it's always extremely dangerous.
Because then it's a really active front,
the thunderstorms are very strong, and
they really come through in a line.
And if you see such a thunderstorm line
on the weather radar, I would
personally land really quickly,
even if the thunderstorms are still 100 km away,
and the strong wind also gets pushed ahead.
And then you can get cold-air outflows
from the thunderstorm, which are very, very dangerous
for paraglider pilots,
which we'll look at
in the thunderstorm section
of this theory course in more detail.
But here about the weather radar.
Important on the weather radar, another practical tip:
don't just look at the radar,
but also look at the sky,
because the radar images are usually
a quarter-hour old, or even half an hour,
depending — make sure they're current.
But also look up at the sky,
not just at your phone when you go flying.
And one little addition
about thunderstorms.
The closer
to the center of a low-pressure area,
for instance — that you
move within this front,
the more active the cold front is.
If you're only brushed
by the very outermost tip of this front,
like here in the case of Greece,
it can be that the whole weather phenomenon
is just a bit weaker
and not really that bad,
maybe still flyable. But be careful,
that has a lot to do with experience.
But if you really get hit
full-on in the middle of a cold front,
then it's really very active
and then definitely no flying.
But if you're only brushed,
you can sometimes
still go flying
and it leads to a slight
destabilization of the air mass.
But that's more for advanced pilots.
But good to know,
this gradient — that a front
in the center is always stronger
than in the outermost areas of the front.
Then we come to the
second frontal phenomenon,
and that's the warm front.
With the warm front,
a warmer air mass,
as we've seen,
is forced to glide up onto a colder air mass.
With air masses it's always about
which one is colder or warmer.
It doesn't mean per se that one is warm.
You could have an air mass
at minus 20 degrees
and the other air mass at minus 10.
That's also cold, but it's colder.
So a warmer air mass
comes in.
And so the air mass
is less dense, a bit lighter,
and it glides up
on top of the cold air mass.
So
a warm front comes in in a wedge shape.
You can remember this:
the diagonal line, the air mass
that gets lifted, forms
a diagonal line.
This makes it for us paraglider pilots
much less dangerous
than a teardrop shape.
If I'm standing down here on the mountain
and want to fly, I see
a lot. Earlier, before the front
even reaches the ground,
I see high cloud layers.
The sky gets milkier and milkier.
It's not really nice
for flying anyway.
The air mass keeps coming
lower and lower, and then you notice
that it's not
good flying weather.
So the warm front is much less dangerous
than the cold front. But logically
you also wouldn't fly in a warm front.
Of course that's always combined with wind.
What you also see is
a warm front comes in much
more slowly.
It comes in at 15 to 25 km/h.
It takes 12 to 24
sometimes more hours
to pass over Switzerland.
That's usually a somewhat longer affair.
It can sometimes also be two days
of flying weather in a warm front.
And in the lead-up,
as already discussed, it brings high shading,
which weakens the thermal
activity and
doesn't really bring great flying weather.
With a warm front the
only problem there might be —
also for mountaineers for example —
is that when I'm down here,
I can't see through the cloud doors,
and see what's behind.
Even with a warm front, behind it
thunderstorms can sometimes form.
Especially with an occlusion,
which we'll get to in a moment,
there can be huge thunderstorm towers behind,
which are of course very dangerous,
because they bring the weather with them,
strong wind, heavy precipitation,
and you can't even see them,
because the cloud layers are covering everything.
By the way, you can see here the cloud names
that come with a warm front.
You'll have to learn those as well.
We'll look at the cloud names later.
But for you to know,
the warm front usually comes
with stratus clouds.
So we have cirrostratus, altostratus,
nimbostratus — it's always tied to stratus.
What stratus means
and what these cloud names are
and what they look like,
we'll hear in another chapter,
when we look at cloud names.
But remember:
cirrostratus, altostratus, nimbostratus
will very likely be
asked on the theory exam.
When these cloud forms appear,
you can already start to think
of a warm front in the back of your mind.
Here are the pictures
of how it comes in.
The clouds look like this,
they are layered clouds.
These are the cloud decks
that come lower and lower
as the front progresses.
And that's roughly what these cloud forms look like.
Then we come
to the chapter on occlusions.
Occlusions —
you don't actually need to know
extremely much about them.
But it does still come up on the theory exam.
It's a mixed form of these two fronts.
And as discussed,
what's relevant for us
in practice is mainly that
with an occlusion the sky
is often covered
and there are what's called masked thunderstorms.
Those are thunderstorm towers behind it,
because the warm front gets caught up.
It's faster.
There can be thunderstorms behind.
But if we're up front,
we maybe don't even see the thunderstorm towers.
And that's really important for us
to know that this can happen.
A very detailed question
that doesn't have a whole lot to do with flight practice
or that for most paraglider pilots
isn't of much relevance,
is the character of occlusions.
That also comes up on the exam.
There's what's called an occlusion
with cold-front character
and an occlusion
with warm-front character.
So when you see an occlusion image
with the two dividing lines
of the air masses,
just check which dividing line touches the ground.
Accordingly,
in this case the line
of the cold front touches the ground
and in the other case
the line of
the warm front touches the ground —
with cold-front character and warm-front character.
Up here in this graphic you see
a cold-front character.
You need to learn that for the theory exam.
But it's not really that relevant
what the differences are
for normal pilots.
Here I'd like to very briefly
summarize a few tips.
These are the two charts
that come up most on the theory exam.
Maybe on the left chart, summarized once more
as a recap.
We have different pressure areas.
Think about: where is the low pressure?
Where is the high pressure?
How do the air masses rotate accordingly?
High pressure clockwise,
low pressure counterclockwise.
Then you've got the wind direction.
Picture the compass rose.
Which direction is the wind coming from?
Degrees accordingly.
When the isobar lines are close together,
we have very strong wind,
as in this case in Stockholm.
If they're far apart,
we have relatively weak wind.
I sometimes use Switzerland as an example.
If the isobars,
taking Switzerland's size,
are equally close together,
important at 5 hPa intervals,
then we have relatively strong wind.
Once the isobars are further apart,
like maybe twice
or three times as wide as Switzerland,
then we have really weak winds.
So here in the Mediterranean region
we have a very low-wind area,
and also in the center of the high pressure relatively low wind.
So that's for reading wind direction
and wind strength.
Then you'll be asked using this chart.
Then we have the two charts here.
Here you see the fronts as well.
For this you mainly need to know
what cloud forms
come with the fronts.
Here we have for sure
thunderstorms in the cold front.
We might have
a bit of cumulus clouds ahead.
And here,
sorry, I just made a mistake.
We have here a cold front —
the triangles are really important.
The shapes of the symbols are important.
So we have triangles here,
that's a cold front.
Thunderstorms are definitely a topic here.
And here we have a warm front,
leading the way with these round symbols.
So accordingly we have
the stratus clouds, as we just discussed.
And we have a high pressure and a low pressure.
Of course in the low pressure
with these sharper lines,
it's always about precipitation.
Here it's certainly raining up in Stockholm.
And for example in Athens
we have high-pressure influence
with nice weather.
There's a multiple-choice learning tool
that you can click through.
And you keep being reminded
of the basic principles
that we just discussed,
with these two charts.
Then you'll be well prepared
for the exam,
as far as isobar charts and fronts go.
Then we come to a huge topic
that's important
to understand in depth
if you really want to fly paragliders well,
if you want to fly cross-country,
and that's thermals.
I'd suggest
we take a quick break,
so you can have something to drink,
and clear your head.
The course still goes on for a long time —
we have a lot more to discuss.
So that would maybe be a moment,
when we start the next chapter.